with the john maddux price we're looking
for something a bit more than what
people are expected to do as part of
their role part of their job we're
looking for people who have made an area
of discussion of public discussion
they're responsive industry we want to
reward someone who we feel has devoted a
large chunk of their time to defending
their science and campaigning for their
science what actually really made the
decision for us was the extent to which
this person had not just stood up for
science but had spoken truth to power
had taken those arguments often
unpopular arguments into places where
they really needed to be heard it's
never an easy decision when there are
several strong candidates but we
certainly had a clear consensus that we
had an outstanding winner this time
round someone who had a sustained record
of engagement with one of the most
important areas of current controversy
I'm really delighted at the 2013 John
Maddox prize winner is David loved
David Nutt is professor of
neuropsychopharmacology too many of us
what that means is the study of the
effect of drugs on the brain and all
other aspects of our lives and what
David has done is brought a discussion
about evidence right to the heart of
many of those very tricky political and
social debates about drugs there's a lot
of a misapprehension about the relative
risks of different kinds of drugs and he
has always insisted that evidence is
needed in order that politicians should
be able to decide on the basis of
overall criteria what the classification
should be of those drugs I nominated
David because I think he's a man with
scientific integrity and personal
integrity and somebody who cares
passionately about in justices in the
world I think what we admire most about
the prize winner was his ability to pick
himself up after a really severe attack
David had they had the difficulty of
pursuing his own academic scientific and
clinical interest in drugs in parallel
with being the chair of a government
committee but some of his communications
were taken by by the governor by
government ministers as being too much
of a direct intervention in the process
of developing policy and to too much of
a criticism of of individual politicians
including ministers I think he was a you
know he was an irritant within within
government and and in the end was
summarily dismissed people often say to
me walk in it why did you take the job
if you knew that people wouldn't going
to be accepting your opinions we know
and I said well actually that's not true
you know I thought maybe naively that
you know government scientific advisors
actually were there to advise the
government on science and one thing's
for sure i am i will never i will
never subjugate knowledge of the truth
simply to appease a politician
politicians come and go they could
disappear overnight any any Minister you
talk to it could be there one day gone
the next but the science is there it's
forever and scientist have really got to
stand up for them to be dismissed by
home secretary by a senior government
minister by a member of the cabinet
would have destroyed lesser people and
he didn't he rose to the challenge he
defended himself and his his actions um
and he moved on into new areas exploring
the scientific evidence for our
attitudes to to drugs I'm going to tell
you about it I'm gonna tell you about
what you want to come and see this image
right cousin no it's really good you'll
think you'll be fascinated by it
something we dug David schedule is quite
remarkable he's not only I'm actively
involved with his some research group
he's also a clinician he's a practicing
psychiatrist so he has clinics he sees
patients and he gives a lot of his time
to talk to the public the essence of why
I nominated David is that he just is so
tireless in his defense of the evidence
I mean where most people might after
flying back from some country or other
want to rest he'll go straight out to
talk to a public meeting in terms of
standing up for science that's what he
does every day and I can't think of
anyone better to receive the award ready
but I told you about this stuff from
that field tonight he's ultra high
frequency I'm often asked the question
you know what would you do it again do
you have regrets in and what did you
know in hindsight was it the right thing
to do and the answer is that I certainly
didn't enjoy it it was a very stressful
period although you know I thanks to the
media I managed to really get my
argument across so I think in the end
the debate was better served by me being
sacked I think the oxygen of publicity
actually got the argument into the
public domain very well
I I don't think I could have done
anything differently I just it's not in
my nature I cannot sit in front of a
camera and tallahassee Valley I always
been a bit like that other words I'm not
a politician I'm a scientist oh hi is
Amanda their fees David Nutt
you